Speaker 1: Welcome back to the show, let's
go to this week's mailbag, an increasingly
popular segment with the lovers and the haters
of the David Pakman show.
You can email info at David Pakman dot com.
Please don't abuse the email address, guys.
There's so many people that we just have to
block from our email and filter their emails
to where they belong right into the trash,
but it's still great hearing from from so
many of you.
Before we jump into the email piece, let's
do like one little extra, which is a tweet
response, and this goes to remember my Monday
segment about I'm no longer going to apologize
to the idiots sort of thing.
Here was like I tweeted about Russia this
week and someone wrote back, Dude, you're
regurgitating CIA talking points.
What a loser take.
Give me a break.
They would go away.
I don't care what you think and I'm not doing
the show for you.
You can go away, find some show that is more
pleasant for you.
But we I just don't care.
I just don't care.
I've had the other one.
Is you regurgitating DNC talking points, man?
We're not paid by the DNC.
I have no contact with anyone at the CIA.
I don't even know what CIA talking points
are when it comes to this.
I just don't care.
The show is not for you.
Please move on.
No longer explaining away or apologizing,
Corey wrote in and had a very good reminder.
Corey said What happened to Obama Gate, sir?
At one point, Trump declared Obama Gate as
the crime of the century.
He never detailed it, but claimed everyone
knew what it was and the evidence was going
to come out.
I know that it's just part of the Trump grift,
but when these claims never come to fruition,
how do otherwise intelligent people keep falling
for this?
Well, they're not really otherwise intelligent,
Corey.
Is it a matter of personality cult brainwashing,
or do people just want to be insiders and
pretend to be in on the grift?
There's different reasons why different people
fall for obvious lies.
Yeah, if you don't remember the whole Obama
gate thing, Trump at one point started using
that term Obama gate and saying it's the biggest
political crime of the century.
And a lot of people would ask like reporters,
What is it?
And Trump would go, You know what it is and
would attack the media.
And the evidence was always just on the brink
of coming out.
And of course, like it never did.
It never did come out.
And I don't know what Obama was.
Was Obama Gate Dems.
They spied on my campaign.
Was Obama Gate.
The tan suit was Obama Gate when Trump, when
Obama had a particular type of mustard on
a burger?
I don't know at this point what Obama Gate
was supposed to be, but rest assured it doesn't
exist.
It doesn't exist.
A very strong shot across the bow fired by
Ralph.
Ralph wrote in and said, Harry, situation,
David, no politics in this email.
I just wanted to let you know that your facial
hair is much better than Farron Cousins.
Not as good as Bret Erlich, though.
I love your show.
Watch it every day on YouTube.
Keep up the good work.
This is extraordinarily divisive, extraordinarily
divisive, and I would encourage Ralph to rethink
right in about something less divisive, like,
you know, the Israeli-Palestinian conflict
or something like that.
Now, in all seriousness, I can barely grow
a beard, so I don't even know.
I did not expect any commentary on my facial
hair, nor do I have anything to brag about.
Quite frankly, I just this is when I don't
shave for two weeks.
This is what it looks like, and it's pathetic.
And that's OK.
But that's it.
I don't have anything else to add about that.
Will wrote in about Trump's presidential portrait,
says, Hey, David, really enjoy the show in
the way you discuss news, almost all of which
I agree with.
One small point I don't agree with you on
is Marjorie Taylor Greene's use of gazpacho
instead of Gestapo.
I in no way support her on anything.
But I do think she said gazpacho on purpose
to ridicule Pelosi, to attract more attention
and to rile US libs.
It was not a slip of the tongue or an indication
of her ignorance, as if any more were needed.
I disagree.
And the reason I disagree is, number one,
I don't think Marjorie Taylor Greene is smart
enough to think of that.
And number two, it's not really helped her
in any way that she has been widely ridiculed
for saying gazpacho instead of Gestapo.
It's not gotten more people to agree that
Nancy Pelosi is the mask Gestapo or whatever
it is that Marjorie Taylor Greene meant to
say.
I just don't think so, and a couple of people
have proposed some version of that theory.
I just I just don't think she's got it in
her and later in the email, and I apologize
that it got cut off.
The topic is Trump's presidential portrait.
Will went on to say, Do I think that Biden
will welcome Trump to the White House to unveil
his presidential portrait the way prior presidents
have welcomed their predecessors?
I think the answer is no.
I do.
I don't know why or how it will work out.
This way, but I do not expect to see Trump
at the White House having his portrait unveiled
with Biden standing there.
I don't expect it.
Part of it has to do with Trump continues
to say he actually won the election and that
Biden's not even the rightful president.
So I don't expect that to be the case.
If you disagree with me, let me know.
Toby wrote in.
Toby says, I remember way back in the 1980s
and 1990s when TV news had commentators, they
would generally announce whoever it was is
a commentator have a message on screen announcing
that is what they did.
I figured this was to separate them from the
journalists.
I find it interesting.
Eventually, doing it this way was done away
with therefore blurring the lines between
journalists and commentators.
Yeah, this is a very astute observation right
now.
Many so-called news channels are based on
the idea that they blur reporting and news,
and Fox News does this expertly.
They will, for example, not identify that
we have now shifted from me giving you facts
to someone giving opinion.
And unfortunately, a lot of people are too
ignorant to realize that that shift has taken
place.
They will often crowbar in opinion into their
news hours by saying so here's like a way
it might go on a Thursday night.
Tucker Carlson will go.
It looks to me like the FBI might have done
the Jan. six Trump riots.
Of course, that's an opinion not based in
any fact.
The next day, Fox News hours will go.
Last night on his program, Tucker Carlson
stated that he believes the FBI wrote a little
prayer and then the like.
Now let's bring in two people to debate it.
Did the FBI do the riots or not?
And it all becomes part of the news cycle?
Yes.
Would it be much better to go back to those
quaint moments here to give us his opinion,
which is not the opinion of this network and
it is only an opinion is Tucker Carlson or,
you know, whatever the case may be.
Toby absolutely spot on observation, Joseph
wrote in and says, David, sir, your comparison
about high schoolers asking questions to Milton
Friedman versus the modern day high schoolers
asking questions to Ben Shapiro is apt, but
I think it misses an important detail.
So background What I said was you can see
the decline in sort of education and competence
in that if you look at high schoolers of the
era asking questions to Milton Friedman or
Noam Chomsky.
And you see the questions asked of Ben Shapiro
or college students that it the caliber has
declined dramatically.
And I see it as a sign of the anti and pseudo
intellectual movement and the decline of education,
critical thinking, et cetera.
Joseph says any high school that would invite
Ben Shapiro.
Is probably not turning out the brightest
students in the first place.
Talk about academic standards.
Therefore, it stands to reason that the questions
from these students would be inarticulate.
Let's be fair, you know.
OK, so that's fair.
I mean, I guess the idea here is someone who
would want to go see Milton Friedman speak.
Is by definition, going to be more of a thinking
person than someone who would want to go see
Ben Shapiro speak.
I don't know.
I mean, there might be something to that.
There might be something to that.
But I think part of the issue part of the
decline is in who people want to go and see
speak.
And I think that there's been a dramatic change
there as well.
So a fair point, but I don't know that it
really tells us everything we need to know.
Damian writes in and says about the midterms
David, why does everyone assume Republicans
will take back the House in 2002, despite
the fact that Democrats took back the White
House and Senate in 2021?
Well, first of all, there was 2020.
But that is why.
So, Damian, here here's what you have to understand.
If you didn't know the history of American
politics, you might think, well, Democrats
did well in 2020.
So by definition, they have momentum going
into 2021 2022.
Not the way it works historically, when one
party wins back the White House in one election
year in the next immediate midterm.
The other party takes back control of the
House and or Senate or extends their control,
and we can talk about why that is.
Often there's sort of this idea of a pendulum
that when it swings one way, it then comes
back and swings the other way.
A lot of different reasons, but historically,
that's the way it happens.
Usually when one party takes the White House,
they then lose the House and or Senate.
So that's why we expect it to happen.
And indeed, it is looking that way.
Unfortunately, last email is from Glen Glen,
says David.
Love your show, but I'm not a fan of you referring
to Mike Lindell as pillow.
He's definitely an unhinged man worthy of
your ire.
But by referring to him as pillow, I feel
that you're lowering yourself to Trump's level
of using derogatory nicknames.
For those that displease him, though, pillow
isn't really that derogatory just appears
unseemly beneath you.
I would prefer you refer to him by his real
name.
I kind of disagree.
Listen, Pillow is not a serious person.
Mike Lindell is not a serious person.
And part of making it clear that, you know,
it's not.
Senator Mitt Romney has taken a position on
tax reform, and we're not going to call him
mittens, right?
I mean, I would agree with you there pillows,
not a serious person.
And the fact that Mike Pillow has even gotten
a place in American politics thanks to Trump,
who is also not serious.
I believe at every level we need to be ridiculing
the fact that this guy has a voice.
And so I think in his case, referring to him
as pillow is absolutely fine.
Anecdotally, I think people in the audience
tend to agree with me on that one.
If you disagree by all means, let me know.
We also have a great bonus show coming up
for you today.
The bonus show is for our website members.
We depend on website members to fund this
show.
You know, we've got CPAC going on right now
and CPAC is wild, cartoonish, reactionary
extremism, and we should laugh at it.
But but but but remember, CPAC should also
be a reminder.
And how much more seriously the right takes
funding organization for right wing media
and right wing politics?
OK.
On the left, we think at it, the right crushes
us with funding, right with wing media funding,
right wing conferences.
So remember, let's support media we think
is doing something valuable.
If you think this show is doing something
valuable, consider getting a membership at
Join Packman dot com.
It's very cheap and you'll get access to the
Daily Bonus Show every day.
You'll get a commercial free audio and video
feed of the full show every day, six hours
before it publishes for everybody else, and
you'll be supporting something that hopefully
you think is worthwhile.
Sign up at Join Packman dot com.
We have a coupon code you can use if you want.
That code is Wow 22.
Wow 22.
Unidentified: We will see you on the bonus
show in a moment.
as we